Another Thing Dr. Bright Is Not Allowed To
Do At The SCP Foundation: Yes, forum trolls
are annoying.
No, they don't automatically become D-class
personnel, Dr. Bright!
Personally, we’d think that someone who’s
lived as long as you - and died multiple times
- would have thicker skin.
But your repeated insistence to turn forumites
like BootyHunter69 and DankyDankyLiteratureClub420
into D-Class personnel is as bizarre and sad
as they are nonsensical.
People need to be truly despicable to warrant
having a place among the ranks of D-Class
personnel.
They need to be truly monstrous, evil, underhanded,
unethical, bottom-of-the-barrel individuals,
and frankly, forum trolls do not fit the bill.
YouTube Commenters, on the other hand…